let's talk next to
um let's go to
why don't we go to darren from the
united kingdom darren you're on the air
i'm ty david how are you i'm doing well
thank you
thanks for the call back my second
attempt so so um i wanted to ask you
about the fight of the evangelical
church in the
in the us because uh um i'm a christian
uh um i'm from the uh the episcopalian
background
the church of england and um and i'm
seeing
uh quite a lot of uh false prophets
charlatans and nato wells
in the church in england really yeah so
what's your opinion about the uh
the evangelical episcopalian church in
the us i don't know much about the
episcopalian
episcopalian evangelical church in the
u.s to be quite frank i i am uh
i i know that they are quite different
than for example
the catholic church but for me it's i i
wouldn't even be able to tell you
the defining characteristics of american
episcopalianism
versus being a methodist or a baptist i
it's it's sort of beyond me what i know
is that across all sects we do seem to
be
seeing a resurgence in the
the sort of uh prophets and future
tellers
some of the apocalyptic stuff um they've
basically all been completely wrong
about everything they
they predicted about the 2020 election
for sure i mean
in england what are the defining
characteristics of the
of the english episcopalian church
well we've we've gone through a
transition so we uh we are quite
inclusive now
so we're we're we're breaking down
barriers with uh with lgbtq plus
and and ethnic minorities we want to be
open and fair
uh but uh but but there's been a bit of
resilience with uh
and we've had uh there's some some false
prophets of uh gaslighting
um and blasphemers and even in my church
it was nearly corrupted completely by by
these people with their own
hidden agenda in your church
darren what is an example of the
prophecy that was being spewed
um um i had a dream last night
and god told me blah blah blah blah
so but what would be an example like
what types of prophecy are they trying
to put out there
i mean it's so it's just to manipulate
people to their own
ends at
grooming really it's a form of grooming
spiritual
abuse that's what it is
i under okay but is i'm just one maybe
there isn't is there a specific example
of a particular prophecy that was
sort of told to you oh
yes i mean because um i suffer from a
mental health
illness um long enough in my life i've
got a bit of a stammer as you can tell
and um and i was told that
uh these were punishments from god
because of my sin and my lack of
righteousness
and that is clearly not biblical
teaching that that is not gospel
teaching
at all um that's a perversion
they blasphemy of the teaching of christ
to manipulate me
to put me down now darren when you were
told that
did that help you in any way oh well i
mean
i was filled with a righteous righteous
indignation to to
to to flat back to to repel
to uh to be and uh
and i stayed in that church for six
years surrounded by people who didn't
like me at all and uh
and i saw them out in the end wow so but
but in other words being told that the
explanation for
your issues was that you had sinned and
it was punishment from god that didn't
help you deal with the issues
well when i could see it was a lie from
the straight from
right it was it was a complete lie from
the office i could see that right so
so perhaps i was blessed in that respect
you were able to know right away you
were being fed nonsense
yes yes but i could see other people in
england and in the us
who are being played and they don't know
it
no yeah wow well darren i'm sorry to
hear that i really appreciate you
calling in and sharing your story though
yeah thanks for the call back great show
all right thanks there it is darren from
the united kingdom
wow things are getting very very real
very real there
the more we learn about various diets
around the world
the more we realize that some of the
healthiest diets where folks are living
the healthiest and the longest
are heavily plant-based and one of our
sponsors just
egg is a great place to start just egg
cooks
and tastes just like real eggs
but it's made from plants it has less
saturated fat
no cholesterol packed with protein i've
been cooking with just egg at home
and you can use it in so many different
ways
just like traditional eggs omelettes
scrambled eggs french toast
banana bread one of my favorite dishes
pad thai
it also is better for the planet
generating 93
fewer carbon emissions and 98 percent
less
water than conventional eggs you can
find just egg at lots of grocery stores
whole foods kroger
amazon prime now and instacart
check it out just egg really is a great
product from a company with a great
mission and i'm really glad that they're
a sponsor of the show